[Music]
how we feeling day one good I feel
useless everyone's doing what I would
normally be doing yeah make myself an
annoyance and pop in every are pretty
good I guess I should memorize my lines
probably warmed up ready to rock wow I
thought this opens do you just look in
them get ready I'm getting ready I feel
ready
bless you with this is usually my Monday
where the old hole feeling really good
feeling um little sweaty I mean so be
like kind of like this
little locks they're good no just
midnight general reason Mars could give
you a lesson on life never do drugs well
I never do that's no good
don't don't listen their futures listen
to your heart that's the best advice my
dad ever told me don't listen to me I'm
being stupid
mm-hmm we got some bubbles that's okay
now boom not the entire series yeah
that's all oh yeah it's a cool kid I
would think tiny box Tim would go on the
other side he's facing this way this is
the Ghostbuster that didn't get hired
okay cuz he didn't look good in the
uniform I had the focus [ __ ] up in the
audio [ __ ] on this all day so yeah
yeah I think we did the same thing so
so that's just really comfortable I'm
glad that mark liked it and wants to do
more habits
thank you mark that was actually really
fun I love that another rig I love the
shoulder one yeah there's a bar here I
think it might just fit to do when does
this thing start could you already have
your hand oh it's a little bit of a
little bit of a Boston a little bit of a
new you walk a little bit of a little
bit of new Joisey I'm always pretty much
I love this man I can't wait to marry
him as the ceremony together the two of
us walking down the aisle just melt
everything
don't cry baby don't cry it's gonna be
okay don't cry babe you know each other
mark 12:30 call
come join me inside Oh No for the dark
liar dialing all right look mmm bling
bling for me doc this is Marge he's
gonna crush it he's got the dance moves
he's got the hips the thighs - doing
choreography for Mike oh my gosh I
already talked to them before and they
were like like deer in headlights
because I was like so dancing and they
were like what and they did so good they
they rehearsed for like five minutes
before we started shooting and I think
we got it in like for what I'll do is
all because I want to like go up like
this
[Applause]
[Music]
they're showing me the pickle [ __ ]
hand mixer burns couch why is point a
and then bambam can be the big guy
bambam and tiny
where's Manik should we start singing as
soon as we go out now we'll get close
animal starts again just so she can get
really embarrassed okay hold up it'll
blow okay yeah that's exactly get your
hand in there more yeah it's actually
company I don't like they don't have
pockets though might want to cover your
nose yeah Shrek not enough time no
stress
I lied I never saw any shadow and
YouTube thanks for having us got in at
1:00 this morning
and I'm leaving at 7:00 tomorrow morning
okay or maybe not we'll see so it was a
very nice stay in Austin brief but nice
now I'm gonna go on a hike he'll make it
sweetness
we're gonna get shooting right away
because we only got maybe an hour and a
half of good daylight left and if we can
squeeze this in an hour and a half
that'll be good otherwise we'll have to
adapt to a night shot we trying to want
to do it's like pretty much only in two
locations today so we're not running a
mile into the cave and then a mile out
of the cave he also knows that I'm
constantly on edge and could very likely
be a cannibal so it really was tight
casting it fits the biggest the biggest
reach for my character is the tan you
got some bucks Brown yeah I put it on on
the base layer for those who don't know
there are mosquitoes everywhere just my
insatiable appetite for human flesh you
know I'm excited this looks good with a
head oh my god
[Music]
are you my friend - oh right there how
we doing good
I have a flight now in like three hours
oh we are
welcome to the sewer set did you
assemble that head yeah I think it's
smart do you have it
in fact for you it's made all right well
we'll adapt the script as necessary I
will come up with an excuse to put on
the hardhat and don't worry we'll make
it work we'll make it work we always did
do you yes maybe I think maybe you need
to put our head on it's hot and I'm
sweaty I'm really really sweaty and
really gross I don't have a change of
clothes I don't have a change of clothes
this undershirt is my shirt no mark man
what do you think for this next one row
speak like 50% faster just because to
get that frantic energy for the most
people tell me to slow it down no no no
frantic just like the hole in this
yesterday so my heel just broke I've
never had this happen to me ever in my
entire life I'm standing there and the
heel just goes crunch so you're gonna do
a shoe change and I think you should be
okay but you see that dummy over there
year your stunt double yeah good-looking
yeah yeah other than I accidentally shot
mark in the chest I'm doing pretty great
I mean all things considered and then
three more days at the sewage plant so
that's something I can always look
forward to wait they went no no please
stay back
and I think the exposure was up on that
one can you do it again no no come on I
need to I need this you know how much I
charge do that yeah I'm free
it's a day right you have a day race
[Music]
Tommy's marking so they'll take some
time
no I think they're done all right what's
up its your boy markimoo back at it
again with another VL og a sense for
very long original glom we're just you
know snakes go away go away snakes boy
snakes go away
no snakes so here come the loser brigade
walk around me i brave it no losers
prepare fish not really I don't know any
of these lines it was great
I actually felt like I was really I'm
fine we've lived in a bus three feet
away from each other
we couldn't talk on the bus no walk
across do you remember when I woke you
up with my crotch in your face that one
time we're G on with Shelly got my
makeup done got my hands on the thing is
she thought it was funny she's telling
me it's like my hands look dirty but
it's actually the cleanest hands I could
possibly have this is all like alcohol
and stuff so I'm all roughed up but I'm
actually pretty damn clean
[Music]
it's working oh that's the stuff perfect
if only there were a space in this city
that is that some sarcasm you're trying
to eyeball me all right Josh Oh mark yes
all right and action
now I need you to respect me and help me
and my friend break out in this place
[Applause]
you think they'll let me punch mark
[Laughter]
yes I'm nervous about this one what what
do you give tonight vision oh yeah hey
buddy hey how you doing and then he's
hanging out my whole
action you made the right call Billy you
did just did you take care of chica for
me hey Marcus so this is prison right
what kind of hole is this now
Oh rope hole yeah don't look you don't
look through there like just a barely
audible whisper but collectively I think
will be a nice robust whisper look at
that friendship teamwork basically we're
gonna rise in urgency and try to
increase the tempo as we go I don't know
if we'll be able to like hit it solid I
could try to like like marching band
style like conduct it yeah
[Laughter]
like no no don't go awesome
now I don't know if that was five hours
[Music]
I mean I don't want to say but I think
that was one take one
that was really cool two three one two
three no over here hold it in frame as
we do it and just lay hold in frame
bring it over to me and I'll be like
tone tone tone hey what's that wait a
minute that looks familiar
oh no not again and then they all weigh
I go and no clear frame and then you
just after I clear frame wait two beats
[Music]
names ready
he's riding the ready way
[Music]
I you can hear me can read my lips
I recognize cartwheel I didn't recognize
those if you can yes you don't mind yeah
yeah
new environments aren't too bad always
hold on it's gonna be okay one shot and
then you guys get to go home
chica that's a picture up on chica I
[Applause]
would never ask anyone to you know ever
work harder than I'm willing to work and
every single one of you has taken it to
the next level in [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ass I
can't curse on this but I'll curse now
thank you
who's seriously it's [ __ ] I am bent
up forever we all have what does you
know thank you so much and I can't wait
to see this come out and the fans are
just gonna absolutely adore every single
second of it and it's all because we did
amazing things so thank you thank all of
you who have people that aren't here
they're dead to me because they handed
it on the last day
[Applause]